tras el revés del senado donde los
demócratas mantuvieron el control los
republicanos dan validez a los sondeos
previos a las elecciones de medio
término y consiguen obtener la mayoría
en la cámara de representantes el hasta
ahora líder de La minoría republicana
Kevin mccarthy lo celebró en Twitter
los estadounidenses están listos para
una nueva dirección y los republicanos
de la cámara están listos para cumplir
los republicanos podrán frenar la agenda
del presidente de Joe biden lanzar
investigaciones contra este presionar
para conseguir ahorrar en programas
sociales recortar impuestos y frenar Un
aumento del límite de deuda sin embargo
con la derrota del senado no han
conseguido la ola roja que esperaban el
presidente Joey dent felicitó al rival y
aseguró que buscaría trabajar
conjuntamente las elecciones de la
semana pasada demostraron la fuerza y la
resiliencia de la Democracia
estadounidense hubo un fuerte rechazo a
los negadores de las elecciones la
violencia política y la intimidación
hubo una declaración enfática de que en
Estados Unidos prevalece la voluntad del
pueblo
Nancy pelosi presidenta de la cámara de
representantes cederá su puesto se
espera que el cargo sea para que Bin
mccarthy hasta ahora el líder de La
minoría quien aguarda que se ratifique
su presidencia Próximamente para
comenzar a preparar los próximos años
legislativos que culminarán en 2024 con
una nueva elección presidencial